when the Sun rises the women of Zanzibar
head to their seaweed farms all they
need to help the seaweed grow our
strings and sticks on the archipelago
thousands of people farm seaweed the
majority of them are women
forty-five-year-old Fatih Mustafa is one
of them for the last 20 years she's been
wading into the knee-high blue waters to
tend her farm the crop has liberated her
from being solely dependent on her
husband
Manu namitha seaweed has many uses first
it's used as food but we also make soap
out of it and we make beauty products
from it my earnings have helped me
educate my children and bring them to
the hospital when they're ill for the
last few decades Zanzibar has been one
of the world's largest exporters of
seaweed the island produces 10,000
tonnes annually supplying China Korea
Vietnam the US and European countries
after tourism and cloves seaweed is
Zanzibar's third largest foreign
exchange earner seaweed is used in
toothpaste shampoos and medical products
but there's a problem in recent years
Fatih Mustafa and other farmers have
less and less to harvest diabetes we
just pray for better yields farming
seaweed is a struggle we harvest
whatever we can find
you can plant seaweed and still get a
poor yield that's why it's so hard many
women have already quit the trade but
finding other ways of making money is
difficult climate change is causing the
seaweed harvest to decline flowering
suya is a marine scientist in Zanzibar
in the last decades she says water
temperatures have risen several degrees
making the seaweed vulnerable because of
this was water temperature then they
seaweed get two types of problems one is
what we call epified epiphytes are hairy
microalgae like you see this one here
the harrassing hair things you see in
this on this seaweed
this is epiphytes and you see this one
is actually full of dots and hairy
material this is then a big epiphytes
when the thing it gets the epiphytes if
it is too much just get bleached and it
dies the family will lose the crop the
government of Zanzibar is worried that
climate change will kill the industry
some scientists have suggested they move
the farms farther offshore where the
water is cooler but the problem is most
women in Zanzibar can't swim that's why
the government encourages seaweed
farmers to not only sell the cash crop
but also process the crop themselves
that way they can earn more money sathya
used to be a seaweed farmer today she's
an entrepreneur running a women's group
that makes a variety of products from
seaweed well Emil iguana in Colima
lilulu seaweed farming was good but I
couldn't earn enough when I came back
home after studying I began making soaps
I took them to be inspected and they
were approved they said I could make
them so I did and started selling them
in daihlia
Sofia and her group have gone from
making soap to making body lotions
shampoo juice and even seaweed cakes for
now they're coping with climate change
by adopting a new business model but
still they're worried about the impact
of climate change and hope that seaweed
in Zanzibar will recover soon